كسر التقاليد هذا هو عنوان الولايه
الثالثه للرئيس الصيني الذي انتخب قبل
ايام رئيسا واسلافه باقوا في السلطه
لفترتين ورغم احكام تشي قبضته في الداخل
الا انه نادرا ما واجه وضعا اكثر اضطرابا
على الساحه الدوليه كما يجري حاليا
استغلت بكين الوضع لصالحها في اكثر من
مجال وبالتالي باتت خصما لبعض الدول
الغربيه ومنها امريكا بالطبع الصراع
بينهما يشبه مرحله الحرب البارده رغم تعهد
بايدن لالا تكون هناك حرب بارده شديده
كما قلت منذ بدايه ادارتي نسعى للتنافس مع
الصين وليس للصراع لا نسعى الى حرب بارده
جديده
لكن كل المؤشرات تقول العكس فمثلا
استراتيجيه بايدن الاونه القوميه الصادره
في اكتوبر الماضي ترى الصين مصدر تهديدا
اكبر من موسكو للنظام العالمي الحالي
بايضا اذا يتعامل مع الصين كخصم السنين
التي كانت كفيله بتغيير رايه ففي اواخر
التسعينات كان بيضا عضوا بمجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي وكان احد اللاعبين الاساسيين في
الترحيب بالصين في منظمه التجاره العالميه
وقتها لم تكن الصين عدوا هكذا صرح بايدن
بنفسه للصحفيين خلال رحله له الى شنغهاي
عام 2000 السؤال لماذا تغيرت وجهه نظر
بايدن كان الغرب يردد في القرنين الثامن
عشر والتاسع عشر دعوا التنين نائما ربما
كان يعلم ان استيقاظه يعني سيطرته على
العالم وهو ما حدث بالفعل الصين تحولت في
اقل من 70 عاما الى واحده من القوى العظمى
في العالم
اقتصاديا مثلا باتت هي الثانيه بعد
الولايات المتحده والتوقعات ان تكون
الاولى في حلول 2028 صنع في الصين ربما
هذه العباره هي الدليل على نجاح التحول
الصيني والاكيد وانت تشاهد هذه الحلقه
هناك ما يحيط بك مكتوب عليه هذه العباره
هذا الامر تؤكده لغه الارقام عام
1978 قيمه صادرات الصين كانت عشره مليارات
دولار فقط اي اقل من واحد في المئه من حجم
التجاره العالميه ولكن في عام 2019 بلغت
قيمه الصادرات الصينيه للخارج نحو
التريليونين ونصف مليار دولار باتت اكبر
مصدر للسلع في العالم وجاءت شيء ليكمل هذه
السياسه لكن بطموحات مختلفه ليس الهدف فقط
التنميه الاقتصاديه الصافيه بل استعمال
النجاح لاغراض النفوذ السياسي
في العالم
[موسيقى]